is willing to pay for the revenue growth
and the maturation or maturing of a
company going from a loss-making operation
at the earnings level to a profit-making
operation.
And this is why, for example, moving
forward with our price target estimates,
we've decided to utilize both earnings and
sales in order to come up with two price
targets,
an upper bound bullish scenario, and a
lower bound realistic scenario.
So what we're essentially saying here is
that if Zendesk going forward into 2020
hits its sales numbers, but doesn't quite
hit its earnings growth numbers,
we should be expecting the stock to
probably be around $100, $105.
But if they deliver and they really hit
those earnings numbers, so the $0.57 for
the full year 2020,
we could see this stock hit $130 to $140
by the end of 2020.
Now, it's important to note that there is
no one way of doing this coming up with
price targets.
It will change on a case-by-case basis
across different sectors and across
different stocks.
But you just have to stick to a couple of
principles here.
Firstly, you're going to be utilizing both
earnings and sales estimates and keeping
valuation constant,
utilizing reasonable assumptions.
And secondly, you're going to come up with
a range.
You're going to come up with a very
conservative number.
And you're also going to come up with a
blue sky number.
And as mentioned previously, this is not
an exact science.
And of course, there is not a rule book, a
one-size-fits-all that you can apply to
all situations,
across all stocks, across all sectors.
There is discretion.
There is common sense.
And you just have to use reasonable
assumptions and be intellectually honest
with yourself.
So overall, when it comes to the trade
idea generation template and the first
section, the quantitative analysis,
what you're trying to achieve here is
obviously getting the numbers right, as
accurate as possible in your spreadsheets
before you copy the numbers over into the
Word document.
And you want to use reasonable assumptions
to come to price targets.
So you can arrive at sensible and
reasonable conclusions as to where you
think the stock could go in the next
period.
And of course, you're going to document
this in the Word document
and literally spell out what type of trade
it is.
At any one time, you're probably going to
be managing multiple trade idea generation
templates.
So when you open these up, you need to be
reminded very quickly with bullet points
what the exact situation is.
Now, what we can do here with our example
with Zendesk
is show you how things would have worked
out if you'd have actually done your work
on Zendesk and decided to buy it in May
2020.
And we can show you how things actually
will have worked out over periods of our
time horizon.
So our 20 to 60 day time horizon.
So if you recall, we were basing our
quantitative work off the stock price at
the end of 2019, which was $76.
And the stock price in May 2020 was
actually $76 as well.
And what we've denoted here on the chart
is with the red arrows, we've denoted
periods of 60 days.
So if you'd have bought the stock in May
2020, we fast forward to 60 days later and
have a look where the stock was at the end
of that period of 60 days.
This is in August 2020.
And then we assume another 60 days going
forward to November 2020.
And then another 60 days going forward to
around the beginning of February 2021.
And then in yellow for our yellow arrows,
we've denoted our price targets.
So if you remember, we had price targets
in 2020 for $102 and 60 cents and $136 and
80 cents.
And in 2021, if you refer back to the
table, you'll see that we actually had a
third price target for $166 and 69 cents.
So the arrows, what the chart is showing
you here is with reference to the price
targets when the stock actually hit those
price targets.
So as you're aware, the quantitative
analysis, for the example, Zendesk at the
top of the template that you're looking at
was taken in May 2020.
And the chart that we just looked at, the
Zen chart shows this date and what would
have happened if you went long Zendesk for
60 day periods.
And yes, the other parts of the trade idea
template that you're looking at as the
example, they were filled in also in May
2020.
So we will be looking at those other parts
of the trade idea template soon.
But let's run through the subsequent stock
price movement and when this stock Zendesk
actually hit our price targets.
So if you'd have bought Zendesk in May
2020, our first price target, price target
one, our conservative estimate of $102 and
60 cents, which was based on a 2020 sales
forecast and utilizing the 2019 sales
multiple as a constant that was actually
reached within four and a half months.
So it definitely hit the price in October
2020.
However, if you look back at the chart,
you'll see that it basically traded at or
around that price at the end of July.
So it's very likely if you had that trade
on that if the stock hit around $101, $102
because your price target was so close,
you probably would have been into that
trade and out of that trade within the 60
day time horizon.
But let's say that you didn't trade out.
Well, the stock actually came off and then
it went back to above 100 in October and
it would have taken around four and a half
months for the stock to hit $102, $102.60
price target.
So if we're using 20 trading days in a
month, that would have been around 90
trading days to reach the price target.
But let's say you did actually trade out
at around $100, $101, $102 either at the
end of July or the end of September,
beginning of October.
If you're in around 76, you're looking at
around $25 a share profit.
So you're looking at a profit percentage
wise of around 30, 33%, something like
this over the time horizon.
Now, if you went into the stock in May and
you decided to just get out at 60 days,
it's likely that you would have traded out
around that time period.
It's likely that you will have traded out
around the mid 80s.
So let's assume you made $10 a share.
You're looking at about a 13% return
roughly from a starting price of, say, 75,
76.
So you're looking at, say, a 13, 14, 15%
return if you just waited and traded out
at exactly 60 days.
So this kind of shows you this example
here based on price targets.
That's being active in your trading and
not holding on for the last dollar or the
last tick.
And taking a probabilistic approach is
just a sensible thing to do.
If you take a position in a stock, you're
operating in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
And 30, 40 trading days goes by and the
stock is trading at or around your price
target.
It's just a sensible thing to do to trade
on a probabilistic scenario.
But if you're taking some sort of a
formulaic approach where you're just going
to go into stocks and trade out on exactly
day 60,
the stock is probably not going to be at
your price target.
So when you've got the chance after 30, 40
days has gone by,
if the stock is at or around your price
target, you're probably trading out.
And then, of course, you can sit back and
wait for a while and reassess the
situation based on new fundamentals that
are current in the market at the time.
And yes, of course, you can go back into a
position, back into a stock.
But you have to reassess the new
fundamentals again at the time and assess
whether you would actually buy the stock
at new prices.
And of course, there's always opportunity
cost of capital.
So given that the stock is now moved, what
does the idea look like relative to other
ideas that you have?
And is it actually better than those
ideas?
Now, with our Zendesk example, let's
assume that you either sat back and waited
after doing your work in May or you took a
position and traded out.
Either way, let's just assume that you got
into this stock in the mid 80s in August.
Our price target one of $102.60.
If you'd have got in in August, as we
know, based on our sales forecasts and
sales multiple analysis,
that was reached at the beginning of
October 2020.
But our second price target, our price
target two of $136.80, which was based on
our earnings analysis and a continuation
of the forward multiple that was reached
in December 2020.
So that was seven months after the May
analysis.
But if you'd have got into the stock in
mid August, around the mid 80s share
price, you will have seen price target
one, the $102.60.
You will have seen that reached in the
first week of October.
And price target two reached actually
outside, just outside the 60 day time
horizon.
So the $136.80 was reached in the first
week of December.
So that was a couple of weeks after the 60
day time horizon closing.
So given the two examples that we just
looked at here, where we're going into the
stock in May or going into the stock in
August, you can see that the 20 to 60 day
time horizon, it's more of a guide than an
exact science.
You're always going into a stock with the
expectation that you wanted to move within
the 20 to 60 day time horizon and have the
volatility available for that to happen.
However, you're also acknowledging that
you're going to be trading on a
probabilistic basis.
So in some situations, your price targets
or very close to your price targets, that
outcome is going to occur within or even
well within your time horizon.
And on a probabilistic scenario, you're
going to trade out.
And then in other situations, you're going
to get the outcome where your price target
one is reached and that it's looking
highly likely that the stock could even go
further on and reach price target two.
If you just hold on for a little while
beyond the 60 day time horizon.
And that's OK, too.
The point is here, guys, it's not an exact
science.
It's a scientific art.
Now, what's interesting about the Zendesk
example, the stock actually reached one
hundred and sixty dollars in nine months.
So in February 2021 and then afterwards,
it fell back from that level to around the
forward multiple price target of around
one hundred and thirty six dollars in
March 2021.
So what's interesting here, our price
targets of just over one hundred and sixty
six dollars.
The stock almost got there in very early
2021.
But that one hundred and sixty six dollar
price target that we had was for the end
of 2021.
So we could argue there sitting in
February 2021 that potentially that the
stock price went too far too quick.
And the fundamentals would have had to
catch up with price.
And what happened?
Well, it was too far too quick and price
simply corrected.
So we chose Zendesk as an example here as
it was a pretty good long idea, a solid
long idea in 2020 at the time that ticked
many boxes.
But it serves as a good example as a
revenue growth story maturing into
profitability in 2021.
So use this case study.
Use this example moving forward when
you're doing your quantitative analysis
and filling out the trade idea template
and making sure obviously that your tables
are as accurate as possible in your
spreadsheets.
Then moving them over to the word document
documenting what type of profile the trade
actually is and then establishing your
price targets based on reasonable
assumptions.
So now we're actually going to look at
other areas of the trade idea template.
And just as a side note, we've purposely
kept blank certain parts of the template
for the Zendesk example.
These are sections, of course, going
forward for all of your future trade ideas
that you're going to be filling in
yourself.
But what I am going to do is obviously
talk you through those areas and some best
practices.
So in the next section of the trade idea
generation template, you're going to be
documenting all of the sector quant.
So if you look at the table here, you'll
see Zendesk at the bottom of the table
underneath the row for averages.
And then above that, you'll have each row
for each stock.
And you'll see in the table here, we've
got columns for PE1, EG1, EG2.
We got PEG1 and market cap.
And of course, you can add some more
columns in there as well if you want to.
This is just a template, obviously.
So in this part of the template, of
course, we want to get our numbers right
again.
And we want to display visually the
identification of the trade on a
quantitative basis versus the sector.
So we want to be looking at this visually.
And it's very, very obvious that we have a
positive or negative outlier or it's a
turnaround or value trap.
So this table will essentially be a copy
and paste from your spreadsheets with all
of your sector work and the stock
quantitative relative to the sector
averages with all of the stocks in the
sector that are contributing to that
average.
So it's very easy to see visually the
quantitative numbers of the stock relative
to everything in the sector.
And you'll notice in the template that
underneath the sector data table for
quantitative, we've got some comments in a
text box on the quantitative analysis
sector comparison.
And the first thing you're going to do is
you're going to document whether the stock
is a quantitative outlier or not in that
text box.
So as you must recall now, we've obviously
been through the whole quantitative
process earlier in the video series.
This is where you're basically putting
your accurate sector quantitative work and
you're literally spelling out what type of
trade this is.
So whether it's a positive or negative
outlier or perhaps a turnaround value trap
or even very specifically on a short, an X
growth stock in phase two.
Now, some other stuff that you would put
into this text box.
You're going to put in there sector
drivers, fundamental sector drivers that
could provide a tailwind or a headwind to
the sector fundamentally.
So within the time horizon, 20 to 60 days,
things that could affect the entire sector
positively or negatively.
So for example, that would be that would
be like the oil price for the oil sector
or microchip or DRAM prices for the tech
hardware sector.
So documenting all of this stuff in the
template is obviously good discipline.
It's good process.
And it all acts as a reminder as to why
you're in a stock and also what are the
tailwinds or headwinds fundamental
fundamentally at a sector level.
So when you open up your templates, if
you've not looked at it for a few weeks,
you can see it all documented and get up
to speed very quickly.
Also, what you'd put in this section is a
volatility appraisal.
So you would look at realized and implied
volatility as well.
And you do a single stock volatility
appraisal versus the rest of the sector.
So this can be done in a number of ways,
as you're fully aware by now.
This can be done by looking at the implied
vols for the stock in the options prices
and inferring a monthly move or a
quarterly move.
Or you can use options prices to calculate
it yourself.
So getting implied volatility yourself.
And you can also do the work on realized
volatility as well.
So you can utilize distribution of returns
analysis and ATR analysis that we've
covered in the IPLT video series.
And also some of that in the PTM video
series, too.
So when you're doing your volatility
appraisal, what you're attempting to
understand is how volatile the stock
actually is compared to its peer group.
And you're going to arrive at an
expectation of one to three month
volatility for the stock versus the
sector.
And then you're going to match that up
with your price target expectations to
make sure that your expectations are
actually realistic within the 20 to 60 day
time horizon.
And when you're going through this
process, you may actually have to adjust
your expectation for price targets for the
lower bound and the upper bound.
So work out realized volatility of the
stock.
Work out implied volatility for the stock.
Get an inferred one to three month
expected vol number for the stock itself.
Then you can compare this if you do the
same analysis for other stocks in the
sector.
You can compare this to those other stocks
to get an understanding of whether the
stock is volatile compared to other stocks
in the sector.
So you get a solid understanding of the
absolute volatility of the stock itself
and also the relative volatility of the
stock versus other stocks in the sector.
And then you try to set your price target
expectations around those numbers if they
need to be adjusted.
In terms of the template, you're going to
get all of this information in this
section of the template and be very
disciplined doing it,
making sure that you know exactly what
you're dealing with in terms of the
quantitative and therefore the overall
parameters of the trade idea.
Next section of the template is the
qualitative section.
So we're going to be looking here in this
section at documenting the business itself
and business drivers.
So in this part of the template, we're
aiming to document the actual business,
what they actually do and the drivers of
the business that are behind revenue and
earnings.
So here we're documenting the key
performance indicators, KPIs to infer the
management operating plan.
So we've put some example text in there
for Zendesk.
Of course, if you're doing this for real
yourself, you will have probably done much
more work than what's there in the
template.
This is simply an example of the process
of how you should go about things and in
the actual order that you should go
through the processes to take a formalized
uniform approach.
So in the first box, you're going to
succinctly explain exactly what the
company does.
If you can't say it in one or two
sentences, then you're probably confused.
And that's a very simple process where
it's obviously a bit more detailed and a
lot more work is going to be in the next
text area of the template, which is for
KPIs.
So in the next section, you're going to
fill in all of the main KPIs.
So the drivers behind revenue and
earnings, how the company measures the
success of its business.
So its business drivers behind revenue and
earnings and forward looking expectations.
So this box, once you've actually filled
it out, is essentially the management
operating plan documented and the
management targets.
So that's all pretty straightforward.
It's just the work behind it that takes
the most effort.
Documenting it is pretty straightforward.
The next step or the next section that we
have in the template covers forward
looking earnings announcements and
catalysts.
So documenting non earnings related
So the whole section taken together,
essentially, it is defined as catalysts,
but we split them out as catalysts that
are both earnings related and non earnings
related.
And of course, from your work around
catalysts, you will be documenting only
meaningful catalysts.
So in the first box for earnings
announcements, what you want to be doing
is gauging earnings expectations for the
upcoming quarterly numbers with the
earnings date documented and the time of
the earnings conference call with, of
course, the expectations of both
quarterlies and annual numbers.
In the box, you should document the
analyst ranges for both quarterlies and
annuals.
So you've got an appreciation and
understanding of what the market expects.
In the box below that, this is where
you're going to be documenting non
earnings related catalysts.
So non earnings related catalysts that you
can reasonably assume will occur between
the quarterly earnings reports and
specifically before the next quarterly
earnings report, because that's what
matters for our 20 to 60 day time horizon.
So specifically, which non earnings
related catalysts could occur that are
going to move the needle and change
earnings expectations before the actual
earnings date.
So the way to think about this section,
and we've mentioned it in previous videos,
this is the section that's going to
determine whether you've actually come up
with what's defined as a trade idea and
not an investment idea.
So this is the section.
So this is the best way to think about
this section.
Think of this section as the part of the
trade idea template, which actually
defines your idea as a trade and not an
investment.
So think about what would happen if you
were going through all of the processes
and then filling out this area of the
trade idea generation template.
And think about when you get to this part
and you've got very little information,
you're struggling to fill this out.
What does that mean?
Well, it just means you're struggling to
find catalysts or things that could move
the stock outside of an earnings report.
So if the next earnings report is 45
trading days away, you need to be asking
yourself the question, is this really a
trade idea or is it an investment?
Because you're really struggling to
identify catalysts.
And for it to be a purest trade idea and
not an investment idea, we need catalysts.
And you have to be intellectually honest
with yourself.
You don't just put in any mumbo jumbo into
that section for non earnings related
catalysts and pretend that these could
occur when clearly nothing's going to
happen.
So you need to seriously ask yourself the
question here.
Have I actually identified a trade idea or
not?
Am I about to go in to a tumbleweed stock
where I've got no catalysts or very few
catalysts between earnings reports?
And if I take a live position with real
money in my trading account, is the
capital just going to be wasted?
We obviously have opportunity cost.
We can find a genuine trade idea somewhere
else.
Now in the next section of the template,
this is where we document our timing and
structure of the trade idea.
So we would do our technical analysis and
price action work, which we're going to be
covering in further videos in the video
series.
We shot a chart with our technical and
price action work or several charts if
need be into this area.
So we are visually on top of our TA and PA
and therefore our timing.
And you would put some commentary in there
as well out of discipline to remind
yourself.
So you'd be inserting your choice of
technicals and different levels, price
action indicators or timing.
And yes, you would also be putting other
technical factors in there like checking
for the short interest for the path of
least resistance for the stock.
So don't worry about technical analysis
and price action indicators for the
moment.
We are going to be covering that in
upcoming videos.
This is just to denote where you would put
it in the trade idea template.
Additionally, in this area, you need to be
documenting the proposed trade structure
that makes the most sense to optimize your
ROI, your return on investment around the
timing and the catalysts.
So you'll see in the text box, big
question in red.
What is your choice of trade structure and
why?
And include the time horizon for the
trade.
So you'll see we've put an example in
there of a call options structure.
This is obviously an example that is
beyond the scope of the PTM video series.
But I've put it in there because we need
to denote and show you visually where you
would actually put this.
Remember, in the PTM video series, we're
making the assumption throughout that
you're taking either a long position in a
stock or a short position in a stock,
whether that's outright on margin or
utilizing CFDs for international traders.
The option structure that you're looking
at here on the screen on the left hand
side.
This is stuff you would learn in the PTM
video series.
So regardless of whether it's a long stock
position, short stock position or some
type of directional options structure that
we teach in the PTM video series, this is
the area where you're going to be putting
your trade structure, your proposed trade
structure.
And this is great discipline because
you're combining the proposed structure in
the same document with your timing
appraisal.
So your technical analysis and price
action appraisal.
And also your expected volatility within
the 20 to 60 day time horizon and your
price targets.
And your trade structure obviously has to
make sense in the context of all that
information and the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
So obviously documenting all of this stuff
in a template is actually pretty
straightforward work, actually writing the
information down.
But the real work is obviously in the
research and the preparation.
So all of the hard work happens before the
template.
And the template is a documentation of
your work.
And it needs to be as clear and concise as
possible.
So, you know, the big question here is,
why do we even bother with the template?
Well, the template brings consistency to
your process via both familiarity and
regularity.
And that leads to consistency in your
returns.
When you've done this a number of times in
a lot of stocks across multiple sectors,
what's going to happen is you're going to
build up a database of ideas that you've
documented.
You're going to get quicker and better at
the processing the more you do it and the
more you hold yourself accountable to do
it in terms of your discipline.
Also, practically on a week to week basis,
you're going to be able to go back over
old ideas and tweak and improve your
processing skills.
And coincidentally, this work is so
important for retail traders to get a
handle on the templates that you've
actually got there from the downloads area
and the discipline and processing rigor
that it provides.
This is what we at ITPM aim to perfect in
the first part of a one to one trader
mentoring program.
So it's extremely important. It's actually
the most important thing to do.
So right at the beginning of a one to one
on one trader mentoring program, we want
our students to become highly prolific in
generating trade ideas.
And having the discipline and the
processing skills to do that at a high
level, a high quality level on repeat in a
very efficient and optimal manner.
But regardless of whether you do a
mentoring program at ITPM or not, even if
you go off by yourself, this is what
you're going to have to do on repeat all
the time and become very, very good at it.
So this is where the trade idea template
is obviously very useful because it brings
uniformity to your process.
And not only that, it brings discipline,
familiarity and regularity.
And this is what leads to consistency in
returns.
The problem is, and we see this and it's a
very common situation with retail traders.
We see this all the time.
It's one of the biggest challenges that
retail traders face.
It's fitting in trade idea generation and
all the processes around it and financial
markets trading into their already busy
lives.
People have jobs or they run small
businesses.
People have families, people have hobbies
and interests, and also everyone's got to
sleep.
So the question is, is how do you fit it
all in?
Well, if you don't have efficient
processes for generating trade ideas, you
will never, ever fit it in.
This is why we have the template.
It cuts through all of the BS and all of
the noise.
So you have to practice this like crazy
when you first start out and just become
highly proficient at it.
And focus on keeping each idea to the
point and be very succinct.
Make it very tidy.
Make the template very, very tidy and make
it meaningful.
Do not write entire research reports and
go down endless rabbit holes.
One of the worst things you can do as a
retail trader when generating ideas is to
go off on all sorts of tangents,
go down all sorts of rabbit holes where
the information just leads to nothing.
Professional traders move very quickly and
we are very effective in everything we do.
What you are doing here is common sense
and it requires you to just train yourself
to move and think fast.
So you can generate high quality trade
ideas on a regular basis and on repeat.
And in terms of quality, don't go out
there and try to be a perfectionist and go
down meaningless rabbit holes forever.
Once you are on top of the basics of a
trade idea, there is a diminishing
marginal utility to your work.
In terms of quality, if in 2, 3, 4 hours
you can generate a trade idea that you
would think independently and objectively
is a 7 out of 10 in terms of quality.
This is absolutely fine.
A 7 out of 10 is good.
If you can repeat 7 out of 10 over and
over again, this is great.
Doing an extra 20 hours work to make it an
8 is just not feasible.
And in terms of opportunity cost of time
and capital, it's just silly because you
can structure trades to limit your
downside if you're wrong.
And just the trade structure can turn a
idea that's a 7 out of 10 into an 8 out of
10.
So we're not seeking to be perfectionists
here.
If you try that, if you try to be a
perfectionist in financial markets, you
are never going to be an effective long
short portfolio manager.
If you've done all the blocking and
tackling, you've got all the basics right,
you've ticked all the boxes, you've done
the work and you're confident that your
work is right.
Then the fundamental tailwinds are going
to be in your sales and the catalysts will
drive the stock price in the 20 to 60 day
time horizon.
Try to refrain yourself and have the
discipline to not go down rabbit holes and
have effective time management.
Now, in terms of time management, you need
to be committing to both a minimum and a
maximum.
So we look at around 8 to 12 hours per
week for retail traders to have full time
jobs.
And of course, you want to be efficient.
You need to be using those hours wisely so
you can fit this around a full time
profession.
Let's go through an example.
So if you work Monday to Friday, 35 to 45
hours a week, that's basically 7 to 9
hours work per working day on a Monday to
Friday working week.
This is a reasonable assumption.
This is where most people would fit in.
So where would you fit in your 8 to 12
hours into a normal working week like
this?
Well, you're probably going to be doing
something on a weekend.
So have some discipline to set 3 or 4
hours aside on, for example, a Saturday or
Sunday morning.
Go over the major market news and the
market moves of the last week and just ask
yourself the question, does it change my
macro view?
Then go over the expected news for the
week ahead and just diarize news and
updates that could affect each of your
live positions and trade ideas.
And just ask yourself the question, are
you expecting any potential surprises?
Then throughout the week, there's going to
be hours that you need to set aside as
well.
So, for example, on a Monday or Tuesday
evening after work, you'll go through live
positions that you've got on in your
trading account.
Check the news for the first day or two of
the week.
Ask yourself the question, why have your
stocks actually moved and have your views
changed on anything?
And of course, set aside some time for
looking at new ideas or revisit old ideas
that may not have become actionable trade
ideas, say, a month ago.
And you want to be seeking to generate at
least one idea during this three, four
hour window on, say, a Monday or Tuesday
evening, possibly even two.
And then you would repeat again what
you've done earlier on in the week, later
in the week.
And you'd be dedicating three to four
hours to that session as well.
So overall, in terms of ideas, you're
seeking to generate two ideas a week.
And in the background, you'll have an
inventory of trade ideas as well.
Something like 10 to 15 ideas that are
high quality in your trade idea inventory.
And you'll have live positions as well.
And some ideas in your inventory may not
be actionable.
They may be stale and old ideas, and they
will drop out of the inventory.
The point is, is that when you're
generating two ideas a week, you're
generating fresh, new and original trade
ideas to replace stale and old ideas that
aren't going to work in your inventory.
And they drop out of your inventory.
On top of this, intermittently throughout
the week, you're going to be logging into
your trading account, either when you want
to act or when you need to act.
So it could be during or after major macro
or stock and sector news, you need to be
jumping into your account and checking
your positions.
And yes, you may have to do this at work,
walk away from what you're doing at work
at the time, or check on your phone.
So when you're doing that, you need to be
asking yourself the questions.
Why are my stocks actually moving?
Does this change anything?
Do I need to trade?
Do I need to add to a position?
Do I need to cut a position?
Do I need to reduce a certain position?
What you're really asking here is what
actions can I take to add value to my
portfolio by trading the volatility that's
occurring?
And then of course, you want to be
executing well.
So you want to be executing efficiently
when you want to or need to trade.
And then of course, always in the back of
your mind, you need to be thinking
intermittently throughout the week.
Are there any of your inventory of trade
ideas now worth putting on because they've
moved to levels?
The stocks have moved to levels where you
actually want to get the trade on.
So the timing has become more favorable.
And of course, you need capital to do any
of this.
So always bear in mind, you need to be
thinking about whether you've got the
available margin in your account for
positions that are new and fresh trade
ideas.
Now, in the spirit of time management, we
want to be staying away from activities
that add no value or make us no money.
So adding no value to our process and
making us no incremental dollars in our
trading.
And one of the worst things you can do as
a retail trader, it's a terrible habit to
fall into, is sitting in front of your
brokerage account after logging in and
staring at the screen for hours just
watching stock prices move tick by tick
and your P&L moving around.
Moving around by tiny amounts.
That is just a totally redundant exercise
and just cannot be classed as doing actual
work.
It's completely pointless.
And besides, you should already know the
risk that you're taking and what the
outcomes are for any position.
So when it comes to time management, just
do not fall into the traps.
do not fall into the traps, the traps of
redundant work of wasting time.
Do not go on endless journeys down rabbit
holes and staring at your P&L.
All the best traders in the world, good
traders are efficient traders.
We get to the answers that matter very
quickly and we get the most out of our
time.
We work smart.
And yes, working smart involves having a
consistent and repeatable process and
working efficiently, which is why the
trade idea template exists.
It brings consistency to your process via
familiarity and regularity and this leads
to consistency in a trader's returns.
And when we're generating trade ideas, the
template gives us discipline because we
have to hit every key point for an idea to
be defined as an actual trade idea.
Also, at the end of the day, all traders
are on their own.
You're going to be generating your own
trade ideas and you're going to be
deciding on structures on your own and
also managing the risk of your portfolio
and taking regular actions on your
portfolio by yourself.
This is not something you can outsource
and it's impossible to climb the
competency hierarchy and become pro trader
level if you don't know how to do this
yourself.
You just have to do it.
So you have to have the discipline to
stick to the process.
And what you will find is, is that
whenever you deviate from the process and
you get sloppy, this is when losses start
to creep in and things start to go wrong
for you as a trader.
In this situation, you're deviating away
from the path to consistency.
On top of the discipline of sticking to
the process and not deviating, you've got
to have the discipline each week to commit
to that minimum and maximum amount of
hours, amount of work that you get out of
those hours each week.
So the eight hours minimum and the 12
hours maximum.
So what you're going to find is on a
weekly basis, it can be a struggle
sometimes, but it's a balancing act.
It's a fine art.
And of course, it's specific to your own
situation.
Listen, you're an adult.
Just be on top of your schedule and just
get the work done consistently.
This is exactly how you climb the
competency hierarchy and you achieve the
level of unconscious competence in
trading.
So guys, that's the trade idea template
and time management in a nutshell.
Let's go back to the desk for a brief
recap.
Okay, guys, so welcome back to the desk.
Obviously, in the last few videos, we've
been through a ton of information to do
with catalysts and the trade idea
generation templates.
Let's deal with catalysts first.
What are the main messages that we need to
take away from the last few videos in
regards to catalysts?
Well, the key message here is that you
really have to turn your investment
process into a trade idea process.
That's what catalysts do for us.
Okay.
They turn investments into trades.
And if you recall from previous parts of
the PTM video series, what really matters
for us here in terms of learning the trade
idea generation process,
and then generating ideas and becoming
consistently profitable over time is your
ability to be able to generate a large
amount, an abundance of high quality trade
ideas on repeat.
Now, this is why catalysts are so
important because you can very easily get
good at the quantitative and the
qualitative processes that we've been
through.
It's actually quite straightforward to
become good at those processes.
But what actually turns an investment
process into a trade idea is your ability,
your ability to identify catalysts.
Okay.
This is where you're going to get excess
volatility within the 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
Of course, we love stocks that have a high
level of realized and implied volatility.
That's great for us.
But what we want on top of that is
catalysts that are going to move the stock
even more within that 20 to 60 day time
horizon.
So we went through the process of
identifying catalysts, how you would
actually go and do that with our example.
And we basically stick to the discipline
of disseminating non earnings related
catalysts.
And this is what should be your focus
going forward when you're identifying
catalysts in the future.
Look for non earnings related catalysts
that are going to be incremental to
revenue and earnings expectations.
Now, unfortunately, there's no manual or
encyclopedia for catalysts.
Okay.
Catalysts, they're just endless.
The definition of a catalyst can be
endless, but it's anything that moves the
needle on revenue and earnings
expectations, revenue and earnings
guidance.
So there's no encyclopedia.
You're just going to have to get used to
this process, use a lot of common sense,
and it will come with experience.
Now, we also looked at the trade idea
generation template.
And we went through all of the key areas
of how you actually go and fill that out.
Now, the template just gives you
discipline because, obviously, you can't
have a trade idea if all areas of the
template are not actually properly
completed.
Meaning it's just impossible for you to
generate a high quality trade idea unless
the template is actually completed to a
high standard.
We've taught thousands of retail traders
over the last decade here at ITPM.
And what the trade idea generation
templates really does is it provides a
photograph or snapshot of your ability to
actually generate a trade idea.
And in our experience, what you're
probably going to realize in the beginning
when you first start generating trade
ideas and filling out the template is that
your process is actually pretty lackluster
and not really up to scratch.
This will just be something that you
realize and admit very early on.
But that's OK.
Totally fine.
Just commit to self-improvement and it
will just come to you and get better over
time.
Usually on our side, what we see is that
within a matter of around three months,
retail traders can actually get really
good at filling out the trade idea
generation template and generating trade
ideas.
Usually around three months, that's when
people start getting pretty good at it.
As long as you stick and commit to the
process.
So don't be afraid of it. Embrace it.
This is how you get good at generating
trade ideas.
It's just practice and experience.
OK, now we're going to take a welcome
break at this juncture in the video
series.
We're actually going to go back to
macroeconomics and specifically what we're
going to be looking at is macro driven
trade ideas in single stocks.
So this will actually broaden your
opportunity set for trade idea generation.
So let's go over to the next few videos
and I'll be back here at the desk in a few
videos time when we've covered the next
topic of macro driven single stock trade
ideas.
Thank you.